ich kann mich auch hier hinstellen und
der liberale erfolgsgeschichte
darstellen will ich aber nicht der
liberalismus ist immer so ich stelle
mich hin und ich bin said und ich habe
voll abgerissen alter du hast so wenig
einfluss auf alles was in seinem leben
passiert also auf diese kausalkette die
dazu führt dass du hier steht wenn so
wenige punkte auf die duh einfluss auf
[Musik]
13 fragen hier kommt die erste frage
nämlich ist der kapitalismus am ende ja
oder nein wenn ihr sagt er ja dann
begebt euch bitte aufs grüne fällt wenn
ihr sagt nein wir brauchen den
kapitalismus dann bitte richtung gelb
und bitte
[Musik]
so vielen dank wir wissen wo ihr steht
die frage ist wo steht ihr der
kapitalismus hat ja den meisten von uns
in deutschland zur relativen wohlstand
verholfen und der kapitalistische
wettbewerb finanziert über steuern und
abgaben auch unseren sozialstaat das
nennen wir dann soziale marktwirtschaft
viele haben aber das gefühl da ist etwas
in schieflage geraten denn kapitalismus
steht auch für ressourcen ausbeutung
umweltzerstörung und extreme
ungleichheit die berühmte schere
zwischen arm und reich mehr als die
hälfte der deutschen und das finde ich
wirklich erstaunlich glaubt das
derzeitige wirtschaftssystem schade
ihnen mehr als dass es ihnen hilft
stellt sich die frage was ist die
alternative bei 310 fragen sind sicher
meine gäste zumindest am anfang
einigermaßen uneins heute wird es
besonders spannend ob sie am ende der
folge vielleicht doch noch zusammen
kommen zu einer art kompromiss oder
vielleicht sogar zu einer lösung wo
würdet ihr euch positionieren auf grün
der kapitalismus ist am ende oder auf
gelb nein wir brauchen ihn noch ganz
kurz zu den regeln grundsätzlich geld
wenn ihr im folgenden verlauf der
gegenseite in einem punkt zustimmt dann
geht der titel gerne einen schritt auf
sie zu also einen schritt vor und wenn
ihr sagt ist totaler quatsch was da
erzählt wird dann könnt ihr auch einen
schritt zurück gehen also euch ein wenig
entfernen
mein ziel am ende muss es natürlich sein
möglichst viele von euch hier in die
mitte zu bewegen dass wir im idealfall
ein kompromiss oder vielleicht sogar
eine lösung zum problem finden hier
kommt frage 2 und die geht an desaster
ecke garrett du stehst auf der seite der
kapitalismus ist am ende und das
begründet du auch mit persönlichen
ungerechtigkeiten die du erlebt hast
welche denn ich glaube wenn man in
hamburg wenn man in einer stadt wie
hamburg aufwächst oder in anderen
großstädten weltstädten und irgendwie
als neugieriger wache junge oder mädchen
durch die welt geht dann wird einem
schnell klar dass da irgendwie vieles
nicht so ganz zusammen passt und dass
die balance anfielen
stellen nicht stimmt und das ist die
erfahrung die ich gemacht habe die ich
mache von klein auf an man merkt ja wie
wir eltern arbeiten wie eltern mitunter
sehr schwer arbeiten und am ende
trotzdem irgendwie es vielleicht hier
und da nicht reicht was hat das also mit
kapitalismus zu tun warum stehst du
deswegen auf grün
ich glaube dass das dass der wettkampf
die marktwirtschaft und und das
grundsystem dieser welt quasi dass es
gewinner und verlierer gibt die leute in
einen immensen druck zwingt unter dem
familien mitunter kaputt gehen und
menschen mitunter kaputt gehen und ich
glaube dass das das ein grund warum mich
warum ich hier stehen meine primäre
kritik am kapitalismus ist die dass der
kapitalismus zwei extrem gut darin ist
reichtum zu produzieren aber extrem
schlechteren den reichtum gut zu
verteilen
ich meine wenn man einmal irgendwie auch
sein pauli durch mein viertel geht und
sich die ungleichheit zwischen arm und
reich an guckt und sich anguckt dass die
zahl derer die pfandflaschen sammeln und
die zahl derer die supersportwagen
fahren irgendwie korreliert dann ist das
glaube ich 2021 schwierig zu sagen es
geht mich nichts an oder das
interessiert mich nicht kapitalismus
überspitzt formuliert ist also ein
unmenschliches system unmenschlich das
kann man diskutieren aber ein fernseh
ungerecht ist auf jeden fall könnt ihr
das nachvollziehen wenn ja kommt ihr
nach vorne oder nicht du ja warum er
definitiv einmal meine ich natürlich
auch die position von von dir sehr gut
verstehe aufgrund natürlich meine
eigenen lebens biografie und aufgrund
erfahrung diskriminierung benachteilung
die man auf jeweils systembedingt
erfährt für mich ist es wichtig über den
kapitalismus zu reden weil ich die
negativ auswirkt von dem kapitalismus
erlebt habe
von eltern tiefen arbeitslosengeld leben
mussten die psychisch erkrankten die
missachtet und stigmatisiert werden von
der gesellschaft und menschen die auch
im niedriglohnsektor arbeiten und von
ihrem geld nicht leben können wie es
einst zum kapitalismus auch schon
versprochen wurde und deshalb dass musik
auch eine gewisse kritische haltung dazu
zu entwickeln und trotzdem zu sagen dass
der kapitalismus alternativlos ist
max ist aber nach hinten gegangen sogar
du also du stand schon ganz händler
wissen wie wir noch mal so ein kleines
stadtfest war ein ausrufezeichen warum
es nach ihm gegangen
naja ich glaube dass das thema
ausbeutung oder auch dass das was er
immer einer politik gesagt wird schere
zwischen arm und reich ist kein
grundsätzlich kapitalistisches problem
sondern glaubt dass es das streben des
menschen nach einfach nach wohlstand
nach anerkennung erreichen seiner ziele
ich glaube viele menschen und es wird ja
leider auch ideologisch und ist ja auch
der populistisch geprägt des
kapitalismus
manchmal ist natürlich einfacher ist die
verantwortung abzugeben zu sagen ja der
böse kapitalistisch holte bis
unternehmer als schuld aber am ende des
tages das kapitalismus frei und es ist
halt selbst bestimmt jeder kann halt
selber entscheiden wie er sich in diesem
system verwirklichen möchte und es gibt
diverse armut forschung die beweisen
dass durch den kapitalismus durch dieses
effiziente verwendung von ressourcen die
armut weltweit seit dem 18 jahrhundert
eher abgenommen hat als dass sie stärker
geworden ist ich da direkt widersprechen
ja klar du darfst widerspricht natürlich
also das hat das system ansicht dass das
kapital akkumuliert auf der einen seite
und das andere leute ihre arbeitskraft
verkaufen müssen um überhaupt leben zu
können und die idee des kapitalismus ist
nicht wohlstand zu generieren das ist
vielleicht nebeneffekt der letzten 60
jahre und das ist aber durch soziale
kämpfe entstanden und nicht dadurch dass
der kapitalismus ja den wohlstand der
menschen im blick hat sondern es geht um
kapitalakkumulation und um nichts mehr
ich selbst will nicht länger in einem
wirtschaftssystem leben das auf
ausbeutung von natur und menschen beruht
und in dem andere die kosten für meine
lebensweise tragen und stattdessen in
einem gesellschaftssystem in dem die
bedürfnisse der menschen im mittelgrund
stehen in dem wird das produzieren und
konsumieren was wir wirklich brauchen
nehmen wir zeit haben für die dinge die
uns wirklich glücklich machen na ja aber
da will ich nochmal kurz ein führt dass
der mensch eine sache entwickelt hat die
wir alle gemeinsam haben nämlich
vernunft und warum hat der mensch
entwickelt unglück nach zu streben aus
welchen ausbildung zum beispiel
christine kann und so ist hab ich mir
auch klar dass wir soziale regeln
benötigen soziale regel ein bisschen
möglich in diesem system liebe du
würdest du sagen viele leute sind
glücklich in diesem system also wenn ich
mich umschaue und mit leuten spreche
dann habe ich nicht das gefühl dass ihre
40 bis 50 stunden woche sie krass
glücklich macht oder wenn sie danach
irgendwie schön shoppen gehen können
oder sich alle zwei jahre neue
smartphone kaufen was das wirklich die
essenz von glück ist die meisten leute
sagen die familie beziehungen das ist
das was sie glücklich macht und zum
punkt vernunft also ich finde der
kapitalismus ist das irrational zu was
wir uns vorstellen können also wir sehen
den ast ab auf dem wir sitzen und sind
wieso diese drei affen die sich die
ohren und die augen zu halten und unsere
lebensgrundlage zerstören ich bin voll
auf deiner seite
insofern weil ich glaube dass die 40 bis
50 stunden wochen total fremdes system
ist und aus der zeit industrialisierung
kommt nämlich brechen sehe ich mich in
dieser situation zu sehen wie können wir
innerhalb des kapitalistischen systems
durch regulierung durch neue
sozialstaats konzept als hätte mehr
gerechtigkeit und mehr solidarität
erringen und glaube ich dass dieses
system das beste ist dass wir haben das
training offenbar ähnlich der bis auch
nach vorne gelaufen ich bin auch nach
vorne gelaufen weil ich auch anjas
meinung bin als mein ich glaube nicht
dass leute gerade absolut glücklich sind
an diesem system es gibt vereinzelt
leute die haben die gewinnen dadurch
dass andere ausgebeutet werden und wir
sehen wirklich den ast ab ich kann total
gut nachvollziehen dass man sagt der
kapitalismus ist am ende weil fakt ist
wir stoßen an unsere planetaren grenzen
und menschen bleiben auf der strecke
während andere profitieren
aber für mich fehlt es einfach noch an
realistischen alternativen die es direkt
umzusetzen gilt also der kapitalismus
ist ja auch ein sehr freies system in
dem super viel raum für experimente ist
und es gibt unterschiedliche ansätze
vielleicht muss man die einfach mal ein
bisschen stärker fördern damit menschen
auch zum beispiel anfangen ihre arbeit
zu schätzen und darüber werden wir
definitiv noch sprechen denn du hast ja
ein beispiel quasi mitgebracht ich will
nur weil weil ich noch nicht gehört hat
profi noch einbringen
er sagt ist das beste system das wir
haben es gehört reformiert und reguliert
wie siehst du das
ich würde sagen dass das schlecht ist
das system
aber das seit seiner existenz eigentlich
nur armut und leid erzeugt leute die der
meinung sind dass nur der kapitalismus
freiheit oder fortschritt ermöglichen
kann sehen nicht dass das nur für einen
kleinen teil der menschheit gilt werden
die mehrheit davon nicht profitiert
sondern im gegensatz eben unterdrückt
wird unter armut leidet so bald auf der
einen seite reichtum entsteht entsteht
auf der anderen seite noch größerem maße
armut und leid natürlich geht es auch um
die globalen süden der eben seit der
entstehung des kapitalismus auf
verschiedene arten ausgebeutet wurde sei
es der handel mit strass klafften
menschen in die amerika und die karibik
um dort rohstoffe zu plündern und dann
nach europa zu bringen was unter anderem
auch die entstehung des kapitalismus in
dem sinne erst ermöglicht hat und dann
in der zweiten phase mehr oder weniger
die komplette aufteilung der welt in
kolonien und unabhängige länder von
denen viele heute auch noch nicht
unabhängig sind politisch und
wirtschaftlich gesehen wie geht es euch
damit glaubt ihr das system ist in sich
faul oder glaubt ihr dieses system kann
innerhalb sich selbst quasi reformiert
werden und auf die beine und auf die
füße wieder gestellt werden jetzt sagt
kovacs der globalen norden hat quasi auf
dem rücken des globalen südens
ressourcen ausgebeutet und hat dadurch
seinen auch finanziellen wohlstand erst
erreicht kannst du das nachvollziehen
das ist glaube ich auch eine unstrittige
these aber was antwortest die 19
stündige these dass stimme ich auch zu
und kommst nach vorne ich komme entweder
nach vorne dass das früher tatsächlich
so war
ich glaube auch dass das heute in
gewissen kleinen teilen der welt auch
immer noch so ist
ich bin mir auch bewusst dass viele
menschen auch noch darunter leiden
aber wenn man das jetzt untersuchen
möchte
es gibt so was nennt sich pareto
effizienz im bereich wirtschaft und das
untersucht beispielsweise ganz einfaches
beispiel ich bin ich bin bauer und haben
acker und möchte pflanzen blumen an
anbauen dann hat man nur bestimmte
fläche anacker und man muss halt
entscheiden wieviel blumen möchte ich an
wie viel
gemüse möchte ich an bauen und das ist
halt so der zielkonflikte man hat und
ich lebe lieber ein
freiheitsorientiertes system weil das
ist kapitalismus und der sozialismus hat
aus meiner sicht den gerechtigkeit
anspruch aber ich an meiner fassung hat
der kapitalisten mehr vorteile als
nachteile der utopie hat jetzt gerade
nicht über sozialismus gesprochen
sondern dass der kapitalismus ein per se
ungerechtes system global gesehen ist
das merkt auch richtig mir geht so
richtig das messer in der tasche auf
wenn ich das höre weil ich mir denke wir
extra analysieren die ganze zeit die
kosten für unsere imperiale lebensweise
und von wegen ausbeutung führt jetzt
nicht mehr irgendwie zu extremer armut
es sind immer noch koloniale strukturen
die kobaltmine im kongo die zerstörung
des niger deltas in nigeria wir sind für
unsere rohstoffe beuten wir konsequent
und die ganze zeit andere teile der welt
aus andere menschen die werden enteignet
vertrieben
und dann verlieren ihre lebensgrundlagen
und wir stehen hier und sagen so euer
leben aber in relativem wohlstand dann
denke ich mir so ich will nicht mehr so
krass auf kosten anderer leben und
deswegen müssen brauchen wir ein neues
wirtschaftssystem
ich muss daran kurz anknüpfen weil auch
das beispiel dass du gebracht hast max
viele von diesen ökonomischen
gedankenspielen sind sehr isoliert und
isolierend menschen und betrachten sie
nicht in dem sozialen kontext in dem sie
leben
also hat ein bauer ob er jetzt in einem
afrikanischen land lebt oder in südost
asien oder in lateinamerika wirklich die
freiheit zu entscheiden was er überhaupt
produzieren will
wenn sein saatgut wahrscheinlich
monopolisiert ist von monsanto oder
einem anderen konzern lasst uns die
frage wo ist am ende die freiheit von
der immer die rede
warum glaubst du ist es der kapitalismus
das wirtschaftssystem das uns auch
menschlich oder gesellschaftlich
weiterbringt kapitalismus als solche das
stellt nicht unbedingt die
gerechtigkeitsfrage sondern es ist die
freiheits frage also kapitalismus ist
das system was die größte freiheit
bringt also wenn man das jetzt von den
ursprüngen von 28 betrachtet wo das der
reinste form des kapitalismus ist dann
ist das die die frei
freiheitsorientiertes system und
kapitalismus als für mich bedeutet
kapitalismus dass das ist einer der
fairsten system das war auch das mit dem
mit das beispiel von mit den bauern
damals in der chinesischen revolution
ist tatsächlich so gewesen dass die
bauern sich darüber aufgeregt also die
ich sag mal die ärmsten
bevölkerungsschicht dass es keinen
freien wettbewerb gibt und dass sie
keinen finanziellen anreiz haben
sozusagen mehr zu verdienen mehr zu
machen weil sie immer am existenzminimum
gelebt haben und dann haben wir quasi
die chinesischen bauern das system
gekippt also ich glaube auch dass das
dass diese diese effizienz des
kapitalistischen systems durch diese
profit geht durch diese
gewinnmaximierung genau ein ziel das man
ressourcen so effizient wie möglich
einsetzen okay das morgen lassen müssen
dass man neben also du sagst
kapitalismus bringt ein hohes maß an
freiheit ein hohes maß an effizienz
guter gute nutzung von potenziellen
ressourcen innovation wohl stein ovation
wohlstand das sind jetzt schon fünf
punkte
wer will antwort ronja also oder
vielleicht man kann grundsätzlich
vielleicht ein paar kleine
zugeständnisse kann man dahingehend
machen dass wir uns irgendwie einem
dialektischen prozess die menschheit
sich befindet und natürlich der
kapitalismus auf vielen ebenen auf
einigen auch nicht ein upgrade zu
vorangegangenen system ist aber dass
geschichtsrevisionistische davon
auszugehen
in anbetracht dieser geschichte dass der
kapitalismus das ende der geschichte
wäre und diese ganzen attribute die auf
gezielt werden wie innovation das kann
sein aber darüber hinaus sind diese
ganzen sachen halt einfach
etikettenschwindel also das ist das wie
sich liberale das zurecht drehen ihr
perfektes system aber das hat mit den
lebensrealitäten auf der straße und mit
den lebensrealitäten der menschen
überhaupt nichts zu tun wollen ja die
gerne verzweifelt doch seit diesen
freiheitsbegriff noch mal nachdenken was
deine freiheit ist dass es für die
kapital fraktionen ist es die freiheit
zu investieren denn was sie wollen und
das ist auf keinen fall oder in den
seltensten fällen in irgendeiner form
dem gemeinwohl dienlich und für uns
lohnabhängigen es ist die freiheit zu
konsumieren mehr also mehr bietet uns
dieses system nicht und alles was uns
wirklich glücklich macht findet dann
irgendwie in den staaten da zwischen
stadt und also freiheit auch vom staat
also ich der staat sagt mir nicht was
ich zu tun habe das ist ja auch die
frage du hast ja ganzen real
existierenden sozialismus beispiele ich
würde die nie verteidigen so das sind
höchst undemokratische system rolle und
ich würde auch nicht sagen dass der
staat alle unsere probleme löst und wir
so wir müssen für gesellschaften so wir
müssen nicht verstaatlichen sondern
vergesellschaften wir brauchen ganz
andere art zu leben zu wirtschaften
miteinander umzugehen die wir uns jetzt
vielleicht noch nicht vorstellen können
und diese idee von wachstum bringt
wohlstand ich würde sagen wohlstand kann
es langfristig nur ohne wachstum geben
weil die ökologische krise ist so massiv
ist in kurzform ökologische ökologischen
kollaps die klima ist es nur ein punkt
davon und ich glaube wir können uns alle
gar nicht vorstellen was passiert wenn
wir auf diese drei bis vier grad heißere
welt zu steuern und ein stichwort was
ronja gegeben hat war das stichwort
wachstum wachstum ist zumindest in
unserer medialen öffentlichkeit
irgendwie meistens irgendwie gut
kommentiert was findet ihr daran
beklagenswert wachstum kann nicht ins
unermessliche gehen also das sowieso
nicht und am ende des tages hat man
krieg not am ende des tages sind die
natürlichen ressourcen sind die
natürlichen ressourcen ausgebeutet und
und das ist ja das witzige also das ist
ja das absurde bei dieser debatte weil
das es dass es eine historische
einzigartigkeit am kapitalismus dass er
den planeten dermaßen für
was ein vorangegangenes system oder
keine vorangegangenen
gesellschaftsordnung jemals gemacht hat
das heißt diese frage wollen wir den
kapitalismus überwinden ist meines
erachtens nach völlig obsolet weil ich
1000 prozentig davon überzeugt und das
solange irgendwie die freiheit des
kapitalismus oder im kapitalismus die
freiheit der reichen ist das verwertungs
prinzip wurde die verwertungslogik über
ein steht werden wir auch was
umweltschutz angeht nicht an den punkt
kommen dass wir dass wir die bestehenden
verhältnisse so runterfahren dass dieser
planet und was weiß ich wieviel jahren
noch bewohnbar ist
das ist ja ganz interessant weniger
jetzt darf bei denic hat er war schon
lange nicht ran
du siehst ja wenn ich das zumindest
richtig im kopf habe vieles was er
gerade gesagt hat sogar ganz ähnlich ne
also eine stetiges wirtschaftswachstum
und immer wieder an diese prozente
denken
das habt ihr in deinem job er eben nicht
auf ihre fahnen geschrieben da steht
nicht profitmaximierung drin sondern was
ganz anderes eigentlich nämlich was also
man könnte sagen bei uns schon auf
profitmaximierung im zentrum allerdings
nicht profit oder gewinner als
selbstzweck wie es ganz oft passiert im
kapitalismus sondern als mittel zum
zweck um etwas gutes zu bewirken also
ich verarbeite bei kursen suchmaschine
bäume pflanzt und die bäume werden
finanziert durch die gewinner aus
werbeanzeigen und da gibt es keine
shareholder die irgendwas rausnehmen
wenn wir auch okay aber die maximierung
die findet statt um gemeinwohl zu
stiften und für andere etwas zu tun ich
finde das ist eigentlich die
daseinsberechtigung von unternehmen
nämlich der gesellschaft zu dienen
interessanter punkt also für alle die es
nicht verstehen weil sie nicht ganz so
tief drin sind also sie haben ein
gemeinwohlorientiertes unternehmen ihr
pflanzt bäume mit den gewinnen die durch
werbung zum beispiel eine suchmaschine
sowie hat wie google zu macht nur google
behält das geld und ihr investors heroin
oder gibts dann die shareholder und
ergebnis weiter und das interessante ist
ja auch das unternehmen gehört euch
quasi selbst nur das ist dass das kann
man nicht mehr verkaufen das kann man
nicht mehr
irgendwie auf dem freien markt hin und
herschieben ist das nicht was wo er sagt
da könnt ihr anknüpfen
also ja innerhalb eines kapitalistischen
systems werden aber gewinne eben nicht
zum selbstzweck genommen sondern um zum
beispiel die umwelt zu retten genau das
was so gar nicht in das super was ecosia
macht und also nur so als einzelnes
unternehmen denke ich mir gefiel es gibt
ja nicht nur kurz es gibt ja viele
sozial unternehmen die sich dass für
jedes aufgabe gestellt haben es gibt
auch traditionell
familien unternehmen die diese idee vom
ehrbaren kaufmann weiterleben und sagen
wir bauen fenster und wir waren richtig
gute fenster bauen weil menschen das
brauchen das also das ist ja teil des
kapitalismus also ich will das auch
überhaupt nicht wegreden oder irgendwie
sagen dass das kein verdienst wäre und
in die wiederbewaldung und sowas ist ein
total wichtige sachen gerade in diesem
system
ich glaube nur dass es auf einer
gesamtgesellschaftlichen ebene trotzdem
nicht funktioniert weil wir an die
planetaren grenzen stoßen also bei die
kapital fraktionen miteinander in
konkurrenz stehen und immer weiter
wachsen müssen um sich gegenseitig
auszubooten ich glaube ich glaube die
positionen sind jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt relativ klar geworden oder was
meint ihr
oder wie ich würde jetzt gerne in unsere
letzte runde rein gehen nämlich der
suche nach kompromissen
wir machen das folgendermaßen ich habe
mir einen ausgedacht ihr könnt zustimmen
ihr müsst nicht zu stemmen aber mein
ziel ist es euch näher zusammenzubringen
hier kommt mein erster
kompromissvorschlag ihr könnt ihr mal
anhören und dann wären wir in menschen
in armut haben derzeit in deutschland
viel schlechtere aufstiegschancen als
diejenigen der so genannten mittel und
oberschicht erstes ziel einer
verantwortungsvollen wirtschaftspolitik
muss deshalb sein
chancengleichheit herzustellen und
armutsrisiko zu minimieren wer zustimmt
darf einen schritt nach vorne kommen
also erster schritt wohin darf ich dafür
dass ich direkt dazu versagen
es ist halt so dass man sagt das ist
diese liberale dass es diese liberale
staat gerechtigkeit die immer gepredigt
wird aber selbst wenn was völlig völlig
absurd ist was niemals passieren wird
selbst wenn man gleiche staat
voraussetzungen für alle schaffen würde
was nicht passieren wird gibt es in
diesem system trotzdem am ende gewinner
und verlierer
und wenn alle die gleichen chancen
hätten aufzusteigen dann könnten
trotzdem nicht alle aufsteigen das mag
sein es ist ein kompromissvorschlag so
musste ich zustimmen das ist du bist ihr
seid deshalb bisschen problematisch dass
wir trotzdem stehen und das finde ich
manchmal ein bisschen problematisch weil
es geht jetzt so insgesamt um die lebens
verbesserung in dem system in dem wir
uns befinden ich sehe gerade leute sind
in dem fall eine leicht totalität
haltung hat aufgrund der tatsache dass
ihr diese position inne halten könnt ich
finde die vorstellung wenn ich mir
freuen
ganz kurz aus leben lasst uns dann nach
dem bundes gilt jetzt wirklich
realpolitischen die 2,8 billionen kinder
und jugendlichen die sich nimmt man ihm
dies mit system befinden in dem gewisse
umstände sofort zu finden sind rein real
prinz gesprochen und innerhalb des
systems finde ich es schon auch im namen
der 2,8 millionen kinder der 600.000
langzeitarbeitslosen ist eigentlich
schon fall wenn man sagt in dem system
in dem wir uns finden sollten wir schon
falschen schritt vorgehen
und ich finde das auch ein problem weil
das da merkt man das ist ja ideologisch
grad
es ist so es gibt kinder die kommen
schwarz auf die welt es gibt kinder die
kommen weiß auf die welt als man als
frau als sportlicher typ als körper
klaus behindert mehr intelligent weniger
intelligent diese vorstellung von eine
chancengleichheit herstellen
ich bin für eine zier gerechtigkeit ich
will das aber ich will nicht dass alle
die gleiche chance auf ein gutes leben
haben ich will dass alle ein gutes leben
haben und deswegen gehe ich keinen
schritt nach vorne weil ich die
reformation dieses per se schlechten
systems per sie umgesetzt und super g
für unwahrscheinlicher heiter ist die
überwindung des wir reden über kleine
schritte darum geht du musst ja nicht zu
streiten oder da bin ich deiner schritte
wohin weil also nur auf ziel
gerechtigkeit im sinne von staat
gerechtigkeit also ich finde es ziemlich
gut auf den punkt gebracht ich sehe sich
als wenn wir das erweitern im sinne von
chancengleichheit ist der erste schritt
einer sozial ökologischen transformation
meinetwegen dann würde ich hier auch ein
schritt nach vorne gehen aber wenn es
darum geht zu sagen so ihr dürft danach
alle richtig doll ballern und irgendwie
auch ihre ellenbogen konkurrenz und
landschaft ist vielleicht ganz nach oben
darf ich auch noch weiter dann kann ich
da einfach nicht so wie wohl alle so
viel sagen ich würde gerne ich würde
gerne als weiterkommen wie kriegen wir
kriegen wir das hin dass wir jetzt
stecken da sagt ihr beiden noch was
kommt sagt sagen will eines was ich
realisieren ich komme aus einer klasse
ich komme aus der unteren klasse dieses
landes ich komme aus dem haushalt in
meine eltern auch schon die herr teil
der unteren klasse waren und ich sehe
dass in meinem leben und da stimme ich
bei euch ist nehme ich euch auch schon
zu viel mit glück zu tun im moment in
dem ihr spezifisch geholfen geholfen
wurde aufgrund der moment und das ist
unfair und das ist etwas was ich mit ich
dich wirklich einstimmen kann weshalb
ich auch zu folter koppeln aber ich sehe
mich hat immer die in diesem konflikt
ist sie beleben in diesem system
und ich glaube nicht dass es eine
alternative geben mag geben wird
aufgrund der tatsache wir alles schon
sehr viele von uns sowohl eingesessen
sind also da sehe ich eure position auf
jeden fall und
streiche total genau wollte max noch was
sagen dann gehen wir den kompromiss ich
würde gerne auch mal einen punkt oder
ein ein wichtiges merkmal von
kapitalismus herausstellen kapitalismus
ist frei also jeder hat die möglichkeit
ist zu entscheiden was er quasi damit
macht also wir ihnen das nicht nur die
menschen die nicht wollen und nicht
können sondern wir reden oder die wollen
noch nicht können wir reden über die
menschen die manchmal vielleicht auch
sagen es mal nicht so fleißig irgendwie
andere und davon gibt es auch ganz genug
ganz ganz viele menschen und aus meiner
unternehmerischen tätigkeit das ist
einfach so sagen ist bedeutet am anfang
auch schleiss mehr arbeiten und mehr
machen und ich und jetzt ist die frage
ist es denn gerecht dass jemand der viel
mehr leisten möchte nicht kann sondern
möchte genau das gleiche verdient war ja
auch immer so die sachen bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen allen menschen haben
gleich viel
es ist denn gerecht dass jemand der ok
damit mehr leistung mehr als eine
krankenschwester in der nachtschicht
verdient die am meisten na das ist doch
quatsch also es ist doch am ende das
hobby aber es ist am ende des tages ist
aber du verdienst du bist du wirst
verdient selber dein geld mit
kriminalistischen chronische mias was
für eine kausalkette und an wie vielen
stellen nicht in meinem leben glück
hatte ich kann mich auch hier hinstellen
und der liberale erfolgsgeschichte
darstellen will ich aber nicht weil ich
weiss an wie vielen stellen nicht die
richtigen leute zum richtigen zeitpunkt
an den richtigen stellen irgendwie
getroffen hat dass ich heute da bin wo
ich bin und ich weiß dass ganz viele
andere auch aus meinem persönlichen
umfeld nicht das glück hatten person xy
dann bin ich von natur aus nicht
besonders auf den kopf gefallen was
irgendwie auch nochmal bonus ist wie
gesagt ich bin weiter man ich bin
relativ groß ich war immer sportlich das
sind alles aspekte auf die habe ich
überhaupt gar keinen einfluss und der
liberalismus ist immer so ich stelle
mich hin und ich bin said und ich habe
voll abgerissen alter du hast so wenig
einfluss auf alles was in seinem leben
passiert also auf diese kausalkette die
dazu führt dass du hier stehst sind so
so wenige punkte auf die duh einfluss
ihr werdet heute nicht mehr den
kapitalismus abschaffen und ihr werdet
heute kein neues system bei denen
installieren das ist vollkommen klar
so weit sind wir schon also nur dass wir
uns klar verstehen die mich auch nicht
total naiv aber trotzdem müssen ja diese
beiden meinungen wir sind eine
gesellschaft ist bleibt uns nichts
anderes übrig als aufeinander zuzugehen
also versucht es bitte vielleicht finden
wir heraus vielleicht klappt's auch
nicht wir werden sehen ob steckt die
köpfe zusammen und brütet eine idee aus
[Musik]
mann des tages ganzen nicht
wer hätte gedacht das ist dann doch
irgendwie witzig zu geht vollkommen klar
bei diesem thema prallen einfach
verschiedene welten aufeinander
wenn wir nicht wollen dass diese
gesellschaft vollkommen gegen die wand
fährt bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig
als uns aufeinander zuzubewegen also
wenn ihr einen vorschlag habt dann
schreibt gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]
okay wir starten mit der gelben seite
diejenigen die den kapitalismus noch
nicht gleich sofort abschaffen wollen
bis jetzt vielleicht ist ja auch
kompromissvorschlag ganz andere bitte
dieser kompromissvorschlag ist einmal
internationalisierung des ganzen des
kurses neben deswegen deswegen die
internationale vermögenssteuer um zu
gucken das könnte steuerschlupflöcher
kommen eine verpflichtende gemeinwohl
ökonomie bilanzierungs unternehmen das
heißt nebel nachhaltigkeitsbericht
geschäftsbericht sollen sie angeben wie
viel beitrag haben sie eigentlich
geleistet zum gemeinwohl und dann gibt
es ein punktesystem da kann man die
vergleichen auch als konsument dann ganz
einfach einsehbar
was uns auch schon gibt die belastung
gibt aber noch nicht verpflichtend und
ein ganz transparentes lobby register
und ich habe bestimmt lars becker freuen
ich habe noch gerade eine und ich glaube
wir haben da vielleicht sogar ein
kompromiss aber ich bin zum beispiel
ganz spannende solidarischen bildungs
beitrag zu wissen solidarität beitrag
gibt es sollte es auch und solidarischen
bildungs beitrag geht der klassik
geboten an diesen ausgaben ist das
magazin bildung so reden lässt ball im
deutschen bildungssystem ferien 70
milliarden euro und bildungs auf dem
einkommens privileg und es sollte so
verhindert werden
ok ich weiße kurz zusammen euer
vorschlag besteht aus internationaler
vermögenssteuern einem lobbyregister
einer verpflichtenden
gemeinwohlorientierung für unternehmen
und einem erhöhten bildungs
solidaritätsbeitrag das ist mal ein
maßnahmenbündel könntet ihr sagen
immerhin mal ein richtiger ja ja ja ja
du gehst dabei mehr so widerwillig also
wenn wir damit anfangen mehr desktop das
wäre doch mal was es nicht gibt s nicht
erzähle horizont aber es soll ja ein
guter erster schritt
gut der erste schritt immerhin so jetzt
seid ihr dran wie kriegt ihr die drei
noch in die aktionen im umfeld zu ja
also wir haben uns überlegt dass es vor
allem darum geht als menschen zum leben
brauchen also wir sind der meinung so
die tägliche infrastruktur des
menschlichen lebens sollte
vergesellschaftet werden zum beispiel
wohnung aber auch das gesundheitswesen
also die krankenhäuser wieder in
öffentliche hand geben nicht so wie
jetzt ein gesundheitssystem das nur auf
profit aus ist das sieht man ja auch
momentan was nicht funktioniert und dann
eben auch so für lebensmittelsicherheit
sorgen luft wasser strom also die kunst
und infrastrukturen des alltäglichen
lebens vergesellschaftet und der
kapitalakkumulation und den propheten
zogen das ist alles verstanden
ja stimmt ihr zu ja nein wenn ja dann
bitten schritt vor wenn ein bleibt stets
genommen es geht um die absolut uns ging
es jetzt um die absoluten
grundbedürfnisse lebensmittel wohnraum
gesundheit sollte und was ein grundrecht
reine verwertungslogik unterworfen sein
sollte niemand mit geld verdienen sollte
absolutes menschenrecht für jeden in
gleichem maße zugänglich und das heißt
doch nicht dass man da dann irgendwie
eine zwei klassen medizin am ende
draußen macht sondern dass jeder alles
bekommt fand ich sehr gut bleibt stehen
ich finde die idee gut also ich gehen
schritt nach vorne aber ich frage mich
wie das finanziert wird aber wir backen
uns unser weg ganz persönlich finde ich
richtig cool zu merken dass wir
eigentlich alle was ähnliches wollen
nämlich wir wollen dass es menschen
besser geht wir wollen dass ökologie
mehr respektiert wird nur der weg dahin
da unterscheiden wir uns ein bisschen
aber haben uns vielleicht auch ein
bisschen angenähert
ich war auf jeden fall auch extrem
überrascht über unsere konsens
vorschläge und denke wenn wir damit
starten dann sind wir auf einem richtig
guten weg
also auch wenn ich natürlich auch viele
sachen trägern die irgendwie mag sagt
bin ich froh dass ich in so einen raum
kommen wo ich irgendwie habe ich mit
diesen positionen konfrontieren muss ich
glaube dass jetzt nur meine überzeugung
ein physiker standpunkt des kapitalismus
gerechtigkeit klimaschutz faire
bezahlung das sind nicht dinge die sich
unbedingt ausschließen müssen ich glaube
es ist wichtig dass man konzerne
egal ob sie in deutschland und an
anderen teilen
der welt menschen ausbeuten einen riegel
vorschiebt dass man verhindert dass
profitstreben dazu führt dass das dass
die lebensgrundlage von menschen
untergraben hört dass das wohl von
menschen darunter leidet dass deutsche
konzerne profitieren wollen wenn ich
mich jetzt darauf irgendwo fokussieren
musst du völlig neues sozialstaats
konzept wichtig in dem wir den
sozialstaat neu definieren anstalt als
das worauf insoweit haben nämlich auf
arbeitsmarktpolitische vor reformen etwa
15 bis 20 jahren einmal ganz wichtig
eine kindergrundsicherung in dem man
junge menschen mit 300 euro fördern
unabhängig dass man kindergeld an alg2
anrechnet und somit das kind strukturell
benachteiligt finden kinder kinderrechte
sollen ins grundgesetz reinkommen ohne
scheiß ich finde das also nicht
begeistert dass du deinen optimismus
finde ich schön
ich glaube auch das wäre mir ist auf dem
parteipolitischen parkett noch noch muss
auch noch in anderer form erleben werden
wir sind über juni stand ist
ich bin sehr tatsächlich freudig
überrascht dass diese kompromisse runde
nochmal ganz schönes stückchen
zusammengekommen ist wohl wissen dass
hier auch harte meinungen aufeinander
geprallt sind ja vollkommen eindeutig
ich danke euch ganz herzlich dafür dass
ihr euch eingebracht hat das waren 13
fragen dankeschön
[Applaus]
ich denke es ist klar geworden so
ziemlich alle in dieser runde wollen
dieses wirtschaftssystem verbessern die
frage ist natürlich wie nach meinem
eindruck müssen wir eigentlich nur das
system ernst nehmen dass wir eigentlich
schon haben nämlich echte soziale
marktwirtschaft wenn euch 13 fragen
gefällt dann könnt ihr hier unseren
kanal abonnieren hier oben findet ihr
ein weiteres video von 13 fragen und
hier ein weiteres video zum thema ich
danke euch